for me having a husband miss
incarcerated is fight we're incarcerated
too so I am Shamika Wilson my husband
has been incarcerated for 30 years
hi my name is anita wills I'm the mother
of an incarcerated son my name is Kay
money Tremaine Baxter 18 years old
remember one day in jail
our nation is finally beginning to see
that decades of bad criminal justice
policies have had devastating
consequences for communities just like
you stop in your tracks you know
financially emotionally I have physical
problems I didn't have and our research
we found that the average cost that
families are paying related to a loved
one's incarceration is about thirteen
thousand six hundred dollars financially
as I got older I could definitely see
that is it's a piece missing because
it's two boys in his 1 mile where is the
day and she has to support us we found
that of the family members responsible
for these costs over 80% of them were
women whether it was court conviction
related costs or cost associated with
visiting in 2013 that was the first time
came on he got to hug his dad since he
had been arrested we came out he was
like four years old to touch my dad
again after I don't know I'm gonna use
but it was like a dream it's too
expensive we don't have a lot of money
coming in you know my son was almost
crying because he said
he said I never get to see you guys
we've made choices to deal with social
issues as though they are crimes it's a
cycle it's an unending cycle
my great-grandfather is in prison my
grandfather did time my father's done
time I have brothers and cousins and
it's just one huge cycle this heart for
us to get out of this his incarceration
he pretty much taught himself how to be
an artist this one here is really one of
those pictures that I sometimes have to
cut up because it reminds me of a mother
having a care for a child having to be
without your father but you're trying to
ensure this child that everything's all
right we believe we need to restructure
the system to reduce the number of
people in prison and reinvest the
savings from these reforms back into the
communities most damaged by
incarceration for me to get my associate
a broker cycle for me to graduate and
get my bachelor's I broke her cycle you
know my son he's in the second grade and
he's gonna third grade reading level and
that shows me that they're gonna you
know they're gonna break cycles to